[Music]
how many of you have ever made a big
life decision solely based on logic
quite a few of you
what can you imagine turning down your
dream job
moving across the country
and applying to stanford
all because your body said so
well that's what i did you see a few
years ago i made a discovery about my
intuition what i now call body wisdom
that has profoundly changed the way i
think about the world and make every
single decision in my life
intuition is a hot topic
a quick google search and you will find
thousands of articles on mindful eating
and trusting your gut
but my intuition started a really long
time ago
it started
when i was 10 years old
i remember staring at this quarter
in a jar
if it lands on heads
i'll tell them
please don't be heads don't be heads
heads
two out of three
don't be heads come on don't be heads
heads i flipped this coin more than 10
times until i finally mustered up the
courage to slit a note underneath my
family's door
mom dad
i'm gay
my body immediately opens up like an
exhale after attempting to hold your
breath
i felt warm and grounded free
and my parents did as many would do
suggested i wait until i was older to be
sure
and that's what i did the next day in
social studies class i blocked that
night from my mind
and it worked for eight years i'd remain
closeted and i would channel this energy
into my personal computer and building
websites
tech became my outlet the perfect
distraction
until i was 18 years old
hey mom and dad remember that note i
wrote you like eight years ago turns out
big surprise i am gay
but what did i forget all those years
those eight long years
for a long time i thought i simply
forgot
my sexual orientation
but it's bigger than that
what i see now that i have forgotten
was my intuition
my body wisdom
the part of me the part of all of us
that knows exactly who we are and what
we need
so what is body wisdom let's define it
body wisdom are the signals your body
gives you when it either needs something
from you or when you ask it a question
when your stomach growls what do we do
we eat
when we yawn
we sleep
these are all moments our bodies
communicate with us
and thank god we listen or else we'd be
hangry all the time
so can you imagine if you could trust
your body just like when your stomach
growls
in the face of a difficult decision
we'd have less anxiety less decision
fatigue and maybe even less regret
i call this the body wisdom cycle it's a
very simple
idea first your body communicates with
you in the face of a decision
you then make a choice and listen to
your body that's aligned with what it's
saying
then third you signal back to your brain
i trust myself because if you trust your
body you trust yourself and if you trust
yourself you're free
and what if i was to tell you that this
is actually rooted in science
neurological research shows that
patients who damage the limbic system
part of their brain which is the oldest
part are incapable of making decisions
interestingly their logic is fine their
language abilities are fine
but it's their emotions that they have
trouble
accessing in other words we need
emotions to make decisions in our lives
and how do emotions reveal themselves
through our heart our bodies our breath
that is why body wisdom is so critical
for decision making
i want to take you back to that 10 year
old version of me who just came out to
his family
within six months i developed ocd
a type of anxiety that felt really scary
i would feel paralyzed in the face of a
decision
and this type of anxiety came full
circle when i entered my 20s
i was studying abroad in paris
and i fell in love with the city
it was my dream my mission to work and
live there someday
after years of french tutoring and
multiple phone screenings i found myself
on a flight to interview for a job in
paris
i remember speaking for hours in french
during the interview
it felt magical
and then hr called
tu no felicitas yones la poste le votre
i got the job
i felt victorious
and then suddenly unexpectedly
i felt torn up in my body
because why had been practicing french
i'd also been rediscovering my childhood
passion for technology
i taught myself how to build mobile apps
and i was about to launch my first app
on the ios app store
and i was afraid saying yes to paris
would mean deterring my app launch and
long term career goals
i was at a fork in the road but this
time i didn't have a coin to help me
make a decision
and this lack of direction reminded me
of being 10 years old it's at that
moment i started to listen to my body
my lungs felt constricted and narrow and
tight
my stomach felt twisted
i was so cold i was shivering
but should i listen to my body
the logical part of my brain it made so
much more sense this was my dream job
what am i supposed to do
it was at that moment that i had an
epiphany
i realized if i could listen to my body
wisdom in this moment regret is
impossible
because if we trust our bodies we trust
ourselves and if we trust ourselves
we're free
when i was younger my intuition came to
be and in this moment i realized my body
could serve as a tool to aid my anxiety
around decision making
so i said no to paris
i stayed in new york
my app trended on the app store and now
i'm here at stanford where i absolutely
want to be
and i have made every decision since
with my body in mind
now could i see a world where
i'm not at stanford i'm in paris
sipping espresso and eating croissants
of course
trusting your body does not mean you
don't get to look back on paths not
taken
it simply means you trust your body knew
what you needed at a point in time
it just wasn't using words to tell you
why
i'd like us to try and exercise together
i want everyone to close their eyes
picture in your mind a decision you have
to
make this decision could be need to made
today tomorrow
maybe a year from now
it could be small like what to eat for
dinner or maybe it's bigger
a fork in the road that could change
your life
now see yourself making that decision in
your mind go through with it
you don't feel too committed to it it's
just an exercise
now notice what's around you
in your mind
and feel your body put your hand in your
chest if you'd like
your lungs may feel airy and open
your stomach maybe feels really settled
your temperature may be slightly warm a
little tingly
this often means your body is aligned
with this choice
you may also feel other types of
sensations in your body
your lungs may feel constricted and
tighter
your stomach may feel twisted
you may feel cold
this doesn't have to mean your decisions
wrong
just may mean your body is trying to
tell you something
and that may be something worth
listening to
everyone can open their eyes now
that
is body wisdom
now this practice is a practice it's not
easy to listen to your body it's
something i practice every day
but if you try it
i think you'll be amazed what you'll
find
there's so much in this world that
causes us at all anxiety
i hope by following this practice you
have one more tool at your disposal
and one less thing to worry about
but as with all decisions
the choice to trust your body is yours
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]